[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome to channel awesome
Zorba report your source for everything
happening around the world in pop
culture and entertainment news
I'm Heather Bruce and I'm IO no aid and
this is your news for Monday April 2nd
now first of all yesterday was April
Fool's Day then weren't those jokes just
so larrya's Oh funny Oh funny boot with
a joke too right reboot guardians Joe's
other one Netflix you done it again
again always anyway um earlier this week
we saw the Deadpool animated series
project kind of implode yeah so Donald
Glover and FX have parted ways on the
project and it did not seem like a very
amicable split because there was some
saltiness involved here so Donald Glover
went on Twitter and released a 15 page
fake script of the series which was
obviously written not beforehand because
there are some jokes peppered in that
we're very topical Jo like Beyonce's
face and the white rhino yeah yes so
there was a lot of things in there that
obviously it hadn't been written ahead
of time but he just wanted I guess to
put out there that he did indeed have
time for the project that wasn't the
issue there you just wanted to make sure
everyone do you say you know it wasn't
his fault
um and if you haven't read it the script
is fabulous we were we're definitely
missing out on something that could have
been wonderful too I read some of it in
his voice do you have like in my mind it
was like in his voice
nice Deadpool yes its back yeah and then
to add to that the animation studio that
was attached to the project also
released on their Twitter the actual
test animation footage that they had
given to the network and at this point
that's already been taken down you know
I'm sure they gotten a little bit of a
little bit of troll for that but that
was also cool it's just crazy to see
what could have been and there obviously
was a little bit of bad blood here with
Donald Glover and even the animation
studio releasing things that it probably
should not have if you didn't get a
chance to see the test animation I'm
sure it's around there somewhere still
flowing around the internet but it
obviously wasn't complete and they were
still using Ryan Reynolds voice from the
movie to animate the sequence but it was
everything that you would have expected
there was lots of blood there is gore it
was very cartoony at times which again
makes perfect sense with a Deadpool
character yeah he was popping around in
and out there was like a moment where he
got literally flattened by someone so it
was good it makes me just a little bit
sad that we are not going to this
project come to fruition and it's even a
little sadder that there's a little bit
of bad blood mixed in with the departing
of the project also this week we got
another like fake casting announcement
and that was Gina Rodriguez playing
Carmen Sandiego we again again that's
right again because not only is she cast
to play the voice actress for the
amazing character in the animated series
that will be on Netflix but also Netflix
is now doing a live-action movie
yes now it sounds like the movie is set
after the series because the series is
kind of exploring her background or
whatever and so the movies gonna be
after that so they're not going to be
telling the exact same story which
if that wouldn't make sense right but
it's also coming alongside a series of
books as well right so Netflix is just
getting you on all fronts with your
Carmen Sandiego content yeah which I'm
okay with
where in the world II read content not
great we did ask that question and you
surely are going to deliver and that
will happen sometime in 2019 because
it's just being confirmed of the casting
now yeah you know whether or not it's
all simultaneous right the animated
series first and then the movie the
books are definitely already
simultaneously being released with yes
we don't have an exact but I like that
it's both the series and the movie is
going to be the same voice right yeah
you know right and it would make sense
because Carmen Sandiego is the type of
franchise that would transition well
between animation and live-action so
it'll be good I like to you know
Rodriguez Carmen Sandiego excited also
this week Netflix has announced that it
is picking up the novel cursed porn a
short 10 episode series now if you don't
know what the novel cursed is about it's
probably because it hasn't even been
released yet it's still in the process
of being written yeah
that's what it seems like a weird choice
for Netflix to do this but cursed is
going to be a story that takes place in
the Arthurian legend but it's told from
the point of view of the Lady of the
lake and it's being written and
illustrated by Frank Miller and Thomas
wheeler so maybe they just saw that
Frank Miller was attached to the project
and thought wow that's interesting let's
let's roll with that but it has already
been picked up for a 10 episode Netflix
series and the book itself is not even
gonna come out until 2019 so there's
still even a whole year before the book
comes out let alone this series so
there's no news as to whether or not
this is going to all be released
simultaneously or if there's gonna be
the book that happens first and then
they're gonna focus on the series or
what exactly the goal is with the
project I'm wondering if they're trying
to make it more like a grandiose scheme
of Thrones vo
since it is Arthurian legend job and the
Lady of the lake would be involved so
I'm sure there's lots of fantasy magic
that kind of medieval drama going on
so Netflix is attempting to do something
like that I don't know but we have no
idea since the book is not even a thing
yet and won't be until 2019 but it's
that good transcend that we really need
more additions to our theory and legends
like just that Lady of the lake we have
a beat that story into the ground I mean
do we do we need to or is her mystery
part of the allure of her character that
what I'm saying let it be maybe also
this week we got a couple trailers we
got quite a few trailers so we're
keeping it to only a couple that we
really feel passionately about first up
definitely that trailer for cargo all of
my tears all of my tears martin freeman
is living in a dystopic future present
just dystopic place and him and his wife
and and their baby are on a ship and she
gets bitten and therefore like you know
infected and therefore infects him went
because there's a 48 hour time period of
the zombification if you will yeah and
so he has 48 hours to get his precious
cargo to safety it's the baby it looks
amazing and really bad and i will
definitely see it and cry through the
whole thing guarantee you with a baby
with a baby zombies and that's coming
out relatively soon that's May 17 so
yeah I'm looking forward to that one
it looks pretty gory too so got some
gore got some hurt though you know
moments as well so hopefully how did
another trailer that we got for another
dystopian future present whatever is
darkest mind and this is another young
adult dystopian novel made into a movie
which I'm on board guys it's fine I like
Hunger Games I didn't love the divergent
movies but the books are not bad I
promise but in this movie children all
children have kind of been wiped out or
something kind of catastrophic has
happened to the children and all the
remaining children in this movie now
have powers and so yes super powers and
so as the children are being collected
almost like are the big announcements
that says that all children for their
own safety need to be brought into these
camps where they can be controlled and
maintained and of course there's a
couple of them that's rebel as they
start to look for the place where
children could just be children and not
be in a camp and they start a revolution
yeah so good for them
it looks amazing the world it looks fine
there's lots of lots of fun effects yeah
it looks pretty it looks really well
done the CBI in the trailer in the
trailer yeah
there's a moment where they're like
dancing at a dance and they throw the
like fishing line this is the one time
this works through me good demo Thanks
and that's coming out August 3rd so
it'll be here over the summer all right
yeah so that's gonna be it from us here
there's plenty of things we didn't get
to let us know in the comments down
below what we missed and what you'd like
us to talk about next week otherwise we
will see you tomorrow on top five we're
right here or you can catch us on social
media Heather rose up for you you can
find me on twitter at how the ruse
instagram at a truce or twitch twitch TV
slash
and you can find me on Facebook as I got
away tour everywhere else as awesome
Ayana streamline it for you otherwise
that's gonna be it from us so we'll see
you right here next week same time same
place in the meantime can you beam us up
[Applause]
you